2017 was a brutal year of celeb losses.
From beloved musicians to fan-favored actors,
the year claimed a lot of high-profile lives.
Here are some of the biggest celebs we lost
last year.
Chris Cornell
Soundgarden and Audioslave frontman Chris
Cornell's career spanned three decades.
The rocker founded Soundgarden in 1984, and
the band became one of the most popular and
influential groups in the burgeoning Seattle
scene that would come to define grunge.
Soundgarden reached the mainstream with their
1994 album Superunknown, which featured the
Grammy-winning singles "Black Hole Sun" and
"Spoonman."
And after the band broke up in 1997, Cornell
remained in the spotlight with a string of
solo albums and as singer of the supergroup
Audioslave before Soundgarden reunited in
2010.
Cornell also contributed to several movie
soundtracks including those for Singles, Mission:
Impossible 2, and 12 Years a Slave.
He received a Grammy nomination for his Casino
Royale theme "You Know My Name" and an Emmy
nomination for "The Keeper" from 2011's Machine
Gun Preacher.
Unfortunately, Cornell ended his life by hanging
on May 18th.
The 52-year-old singer was found in his hotel
room in Detroit, shortly after his final concert
with Soundgarden ended.
Sam Shepard
Decorated playwright and actor Sam Shepard
was the very definition of a double-threat.
The winner of 13 Obie Awards, he won his first
six for plays he wrote between 1966 and 1968.
He soon made the transition into screenwriting
with films like Me and My Brother.
Then, in 1978, he stepped in front of the
camera as a land baron in Terrence Malick's
Days of Heaven,
He continued to work as a playwright, and
penned his critically acclaimed Family Trilogy
-- the first installment of which would earn
him the 1979 Pulitzer Prize for Drama.
But he also thrived as a character actor at
the same time, earning an Oscar nomination
for playing Chuck Yeager in The Right Stuff.
In his later years, Shepard appeared in movies
like Black Hawk Down, The Notebook, The Assassination
of Jesse James by the Coward Robert Ford,
Midnight Special, and the Netflix series Bloodline.
Shepard ultimately lost his battle with ALS
on July 27th at the age of 73.
Jerry Lewis
Comedy legend Jerry Lewis was one of the most
recognizable and influential American entertainers
of the 20th century.
The actor skyrocketed to fame in the '50s
when he teamed with crooner Dean Martin as
the comedy duo Martin and Lewis.
At the height of their popularity, they dominated
nightclubs, radio, and the box office.
After a bitter split with Martin, Lewis remained
a top-grossing movie star through the mid-'60s
with classics like The Bellboy and The Nutty
Professor.
His screen work continued all the way until
2016.
Lewis also became well-known as the national
chairman of the Muscular Dystrophy Association,
hosting the annual Labor Day telethon for
more than five decades, raising almost $2.5
billion over the course of his extended tenure.
He was nominated for a Nobel Peace Prize in
1977.
Sadly, Lewis passed away on August 20th at
the age of 91 after succumbing to heart failure.
Harry Dean Stanton
Prolific character actor Harry Dean Stanton
enjoyed his first major role in the 1958 Western
The Proud Rebel.
He also turned in a memorable performance
as a singing convict in the 1967 classic Cool
Hand Luke.
He was a regular presence on TV for decades,
and he gained notoriety for roles in Two-Lane
Blacktop, Alien, Escape From New York, and
Repo Man, landing a rare leading role in Paris,
Texas.
He later appeared in Pretty in Pink, The Last
Temptation of Christ, The Green Mile, and
had a cameo in Marvel's The Avengers.
Stanton often collaborated with David Lynch,
appearing in Wild at Heart, Twin Peaks, The
Straight Story, and more.
Despite his prolific career, he remained humble
'til the very end.
"Anybody can be an actor, I feel.
Anybody here.
Everybody in this room, everywhere can be
a film actor, if you've got a good director."
The curtain closed on the actor's life and
career on September 15th in Los Angeles.
He was 91.
Chuck Low
Known for his part in Martin Scorsese's Goodfellas,
actor Chuck Low spent four years on active
duty as an army major and remained in the
reserves for three decades.
His friendship with Robert De Niro opened
the door for Low's first onscreen appearance
in 1982's The King of Comedy.
He also acted in other De Niro movies, including
Once Upon a Time in America and The Mission,
but he's still best remembered for playing
flamboyant wig shop owner "Morrie" Kessler
in Goodfellas.
He later guest starred in small screen series
like The Sopranos and 100 Centre Street.
Low's life came to an end on September 18th
at a nursing home in New Jersey.
He was 89.
Monty Hall
Co-creator and host of the game show Let's
Make a Deal, Monty Hall took leave of the
world on September 30th due to heart failure,
at the age of 96.
A native of Canada, his career started in
radio commentary, but he became a television
legend when he created his hit game show series
in 1963.
The show featured contestants who would come
to the studio dressed in crazy costumes in
an attempt to get Hall's attention.
Then they could pick from a hidden prize or
take cash rolled up in Hall's jacket.
Hall would often go off script and engage
in hilarious conversations with the players.
The series eventually moved to ABC, running
in daytime, and occasionally in primetime,
for decades, and later ran in syndication.
In all, Hall estimated he hosted more than
4,700 episodes.
Tom Petty
American music history wouldn't be the same
without Tom Petty and the Heartbreakers.
The band rose to fame in the mid-'70s and
was inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame in 2002.
Petty was also a member of the '80s supergroup
the Traveling Wilburys with Bob Dylan, George
Harrison, Roy Orbison, and Jeff Lynne.
And he sold more than 80 million records worldwide,
making him one of the top-selling musicians
of all time.
He also acted, making cameos in films like
Made in Heaven and opposite Kevin Costner
in The Postman.
He also had a recurring voice role as Lucky
on King of the Hill.
After spending decades in the spotlight, Petty's
story came to an end on October 2nd.
The 66-year-old was found unconscious the
night before and was rushed to the hospital.
After his family learned he had no brain activity,
they made the decision to withdraw him from
life support.
Ralphie May
A comedian who rose to fame after appearing
during the first season of Last Comic Standing,
Ralphie May had been working his way to the
top for years before the world knew his name.
He'd previously won a contest to open for
Sam Kinison when he was 17, which prompted
him to pursue comedy as a career.
After working the stand-up circuit for years,
he eventually released a series of comedy
specials and dabbled in scripted acting.
Tragically, May passed on October 6th from
cardiac arrest after battling pneumonia for
several weeks.
Roy Dotrice
After portraying a Pyromancer on Game of Thrones,
actor Roy Dotrice left this world on October
16th at the age of 94.
Dotrice served in the British Royal Air Force
during WWII and was imprisoned in a German
POW camp.
He began working as an actor in the '60s and
appeared in films like Amadeus and Hellboy 2.
On television, he appeared on series like
Space 1999 and Beauty and the Beast.
In 2000, he won a Tony Award for his role
in the Broadway revival of A Moon for the
Misbegotten.
However, Dotrice is perhaps best known for
Game of Thrones.
He was reportedly offered the larger role
of Maester Pycelle but had to back out due
to health issues.
Instead, he played the head of the Alchemists'
Guild in King's Landing.
But before that, Dotrice provided voices for
224 characters in the audiobook of the first
novel in George R.R. Martin's series A Song
of Ice and Fire, which inspired Game of Thrones.
He holds the Guinness World Record for playing
the most characters in an audiobook performance.
Brad Bufanda
Best known for playing Felix Toombs on Veronica
Mars, Brad Bufanda was also a small screen
staple in shows like CSI: Miami, Malcolm in
the Middle, Even Stevens, Boston Public, and
Days of Our Lives.
The actor perished on November 1st at the
age of 34 after reportedly jumping from a
building in Los Angeles.
A note was found on or near his body with
the names of his parents and a "thank you"
to people in his life.
Della Reese
Best known for her work in the CBS drama series
Touched by an Angel, Della Reese started singing
at an early age and formed her own gospel
group, signing her first record contract in
the '50s and topping the charts with "Don't
You Know."
In the late '60s, she began acting on TV before
launching her own talk show in 1969.
She became the first African-American woman
to guest-host The Tonight Show with Johnny
Carson in 1970 and later appeared on TV series
including Chico and the Man and The Love Boat.
In 1979, Reese suffered a near-fatal aneurysm
that required two surgeries, but she bounced
back and was later ordained as a minister.
She became a household name playing Roma Downey's
sarcastic angel boss Tess on Touched by an
Angel, which aired from 1994 to 2003.
Reese earned two Emmy nominations for the
role and reprised it in the spin-off, Promised
Land.
The actress passed away on November 19th at
the age of 86.
David Cassidy
Thanks to his role in the popular musical
sitcom The Partridge Family, David Cassidy
was also a legend of the small screen.
He grew up as part of a show business family
and signed on to play Keith Partridge on The
Partridge Family in 1970 alongside his stepmother
Shirley Jones.
The pair were the only cast members on the
show who were actually allowed to sing, and
Cassidy performed the theme song "C'mon Get
Happy," which helped launch his music career.
With hit singles including "I Think I Love
You" and "Cherish," Cassidy became a multimedia
superstar.
He went on to make guest appearances on Fantasy
Island and The Love Boat.
Cassidy also performed in the musical theater
scene and headlined several Las Vegas shows.
His daughter, Katie Cassidy, is also an actress,
playing Laurel Lance in the CW's Arrow.
He passed away from organ failure on November
21st at the age of 67.
Rose Marie
Best known for playing Sally Rogers on The
Dick Van Dyke Show, Rose Marie's family announced
her passing on December 28th.
The actress began her career as a child star
under the name Baby Rose Marie and starred
on her own NBC radio show at the age of 5.
She went on to appear in vaudeville, and had
parts in the 1929 short Baby Rose Marie the
Child Wonder and the 1933 feature International
House.
As a teenager, Marie became a nightclub singer
before returning to radio.
In the early '50s, she appeared on television
variety shows, and in 1961, she was cast as
Sally Rogers, a comedy television writer on
The Dick Van Dyke Show, a role which would
earn her three Emmy nominations.
She was later a fixture on game shows, serving
as the upper center square on Hollywood Squares
for 14 years, and she also worked the nightclub
circuit and continued to make appearances
on sitcoms like Murphy Brown, Wings, and Caroline
in the City.
She was 94 when she said finally goodbye to
the world.
Thanks for watching!
For our tribute to the other celebrities who
passed away during the first half of the year,
please check out our other video, "Stars We've
Sadly Lost So Far In 2017."